si padece insuficiencia cardíaca su
corazón ha perdido la capacidad de
bombear la cantidad de sangre suficiente
para satisfacer las necesidades de su
cuerpo es posible que sus paredes
ventriculares estén débiles o dañadas y
que no sean capaces de bombear
suficiente sangre desde el corazón
también podría tener paredes
ventriculares engrosadas y rígidas que
no permiten que su corazón se llene de
suficiente sangre
si padece insuficiencia cardíaca
izquierda su ventrículo izquierdo no
envía suficiente sangre oxigenada a su
cuerpo lo que hace que se sienta cansado
y sin aliento
la insuficiencia del ventrículo
izquierdo también aumenta la presión
sanguínea en los vasos sanguíneos
ubicados entre los pulmones y el
ventrículo izquierdo
este aumento de presión hace que el
líquido salga de la sangre e ingrese a
los tejidos de los pulmones lo que
dificulta la respiración
si padece de insuficiencia cardíaca
derecha su ventrículo derecho no puede
contraerse con suficiente fuerza para
impulsar la sangre hacia los pulmones
el resultado es una acumulación de
sangre en las venas
lo que provoca una acumulación de
líquido denominado edema en todos los
tejidos del cuerpo
con el tiempo la insuficiencia cardíaca
en ambos lados del corazón debilita y
agranda los ventrículos los cuales
envían menos cantidad de sangre al
cuerpo
para compensar la disminución de la
cantidad de sangre el sistema nervioso
libera hormonas del estrés que
incrementan la velocidad y la fuerza de
los latidos del corazón
lamentablemente la liberación constante
de estas hormonas del estrés hace que su
insuficiencia cardíaca empeore ya que
éstas dañan las células musculares de
los ventrículos